Samuels describes a persona in the
following way
the term derives from the Latin word for
the mask worn by actors in classical
times
hence persona refers to the mask or face
a person puts on to confront the world
persona can refer to gender identity or
a stage of development such as
adolescence a social status a job or
profession over a lifetime many personas
will be worn and several may be combined
at any one moment end quote
now what exactly does this mean to you
and I well we all have at least one
persona more likely we have far more
than that
often our persona is based on something
we do or are expected to do in society
such as being an employee or a lawyer or
a supporter of a football team when we
are in this role we tend to act in ways
that are consistent with how we expect
others to view us so as the lawyer we
may always try to be erudite or wise as
a football team supporter we wear
particular team colors assemble with
other supporters and are often loud in
public all the time we're acting out a
persona I find it useful to pay
attention to not only what we are doing
in terms of our behavior but also what
clothes we wear how we speak and
especially what we actually say and
think very important here is to note
that we have to have a persona without
it we are naked in the world and have
nothing between us in particular between
the ego and the external world we have
nothing to hide behind no clear sense of
how to act what to wear or what to say
so you can see that we have to have a
persona those poor souls who have weak
personas suffer tremendously in the
world because they don't know who to be
at any particular moment and feel that
people can see right through them and
that they have no defenses I often think
of persona as a form of defense against
the world
remember when we were small how we
didn't really care what the grown-ups
thought about us how we just wanted to
play and to have some fun we had very
basic personas and these personas were
not consciously chosen they just
developed out of the psyche we were
known as a serious little child or a
very boisterous little girl but at the
end of the day we really didn't care so
long as we could have fun and to play
what makes small children so endearing
to us is not only their ability to move
between reality and play or the
conscious and the unconscious worlds but
also how they don't have strong personas
so we're able to see the real child at
all times this is so different when we
are adults as we learn to persona up as
it were and not let her guard down as we
grew older and went to school at around
five or six we suddenly realized that
certain kids liked certain behaviors and
we started to act out these behaviors
here is where we consciously began to
adjust our personas and started to
realize that we can have more than one
we can have a persona for inside the
classroom one for recess and one for
home as we progressed through school we
really started to work on our personas
because we know that this is the way to
ensure our friendships and connections
with other kids at school then puberty
sets in and the young adolescent finds
themselves in quite a pickle because now
we aren't really sure which personas
really work we then go to extremes often
first with the external quality persona
of our clothing and all of these are
attempts to find an identity and the
persona is crucial in this process
remember I said that one of the
functions of the ego was to provide
stability of identity and personality
over time
well the persona is involved in this
process remember those times when having
the right clothes was really really
important how you had to get the right
bicycle or the right toy nowadays this
must be really difficult for adolescents
as they not only have to adjust the
internal way of being but have to be
aware of rapidly changing clothing
trends which brand us in and which one
is out or which videogame console is
more trendy and which one isn't and even
worse
which cellphone or web space we should
use all of this contributes to the rapid
development and alteration of the
persona when you next see adolescents
out in the streets or in your home and
you shake your head at their strange
clothing or body piercing or language
remember that all they are trying to do
is to test out which persona works for
them those of you that have been through
this with your own kids will know that
very shortly the extreme behaviors and
clothing will end and your kids develop
a fairly consistent persona and involves
not only what clothing to wear but also
what subjects to take at school what
music to listen to and which friends to
keep as we finish our schooling or
university life and head out into
careers we know that each particular
career has a specific persona we soon
realize from watching role models in our
chosen professions how we are supposed
to behave what to drink what to eat and
what to wear but most importantly what
way to act in the company of others this
can be quite daunting at first how is a
lawyer or a doctor or a dentist supposed
to act not only in their consulting room
but out in the company of others we tend
to develop particular personas through
identifying with role models already in
these professions I'm sure you know
people who stay in their professional
persona all the time if you have a
doctor friend and that friend is always
acting the doctor dispensing medical
advice at dinner parties or other social
gatherings you can see that he or she is
stuck in their persona after a while it
becomes really irritating and you want
to shake them up and say you know just
be real so there's a strong risk that we
over identify with our persona this
leads to
sidedness something we touched on in
earlier episodes and a great deal of
trouble in later life but equally
problematic is someone who changes their
persona too often if we see them at work
they are so different from at a party or
at the theater or at a game we get
confused with whom we are dealing and we
want to go up to these folks and give
them a shake too and say just be
consistent now young saw the persona as
an archetype so in all humans there is a
need for some role in act meant to
engage with other people in a variety of
settings so a clan chief had to act in a
certain way and the young males and
females in the clan were expected to act
in equally defined ways we know that
even in our massive societal structures
we need people to behave in certain ways
meaning we need them to stay in a
certain persona that is consistent with
their function office or occupation we
get shocked when we hear of people
acting outside of their role so if we
hear of a policeman being arrested for
drunk driving it bothers us far more
than some nameless person arrested for
the same crime we expect our judges to
be wise and never to exhibit instinctual
or irrational behavior so if a judge
makes a statement from the bench that is
inconsistent with that role we find it
troubling and often want that judge to
resign his or her position the same can
be said for a teacher a doctor a priest
or any other such occupation for that
matter isn't it interesting that we all
seem to have a fairly consistent
cultural expectation of occupational
personas these personas will obviously
vary across cultures but within cultures
we all have a solid sense of what is
expected of how particular personas
should be displayed in public if we look
at how comics often
Lampoon public figures such as
politicians or judges it is so
interesting to see how they often choose
behaviors or actions that are vastly
opposite from their public personas it
is when we over identify with the
persona that we land in trouble because
what happens when the eager over Dender
over identifies with a rigid persona is
that the unconscious tends to burst into
consciousness in severe in unpredictable
ways for example if we think back to the
people I described in the clinical case
in Episode three which I called the
model of the psyche we had an over
identification with the persona and
severe depression resulted this is an
example of the compensatory nature of
the psyche if things are too heavily
weighted in one area of the psyche say
the persona the unconscious tends to
load up with psychic energy and at some
point this massive loading results in
unconscious material erupting into
consciousness often this eruption is of
a severe effect of disorder such as
depression or anxiety or may even result
in somatization now you can see why this
aspect of the model I art learned
earlier is so important to our better
psychodynamic understanding of the
psyche the same lack of balance exists
in the individual who has a very weak
persona you may encounter these
individuals and they seem to need to
exist in their own fantasy world their
own in a world which on the face of it
is a good thing as we all need to
encounter and confront the unconscious
but if we retreat into the unconscious
too far we really struggle to keep one
foot in the external ego-based world and
the other in the internal unconscious
world so overall we need the persona to
be a complement for the workings of the
psyche the ego is vital in this
relationship because if it is rigidly
identified with the
zona it is an ego that looks at words
only outwards into the external world
and is quite blind to the inner world of
the unconscious I often find that when I
start to work with a patient in this
situation and suggest that they pay
attention to their dreams they'll say oh
I haven't had a dream for years now we
all know that this cannot be the case as
we all dream every night it's just that
we don't recall our dreams so these
patients as they begin their work in
analysis and start to recognize their
unconscious often find themselves having
intense dreams each night that they are
able to recall it is almost as if the
ego which we need to help us to recall
dreams each night suddenly looks over
its back and says oh yeah I remember
that stuff all that stuff about the
unconscious and dreams and symbols wow I
haven't seen that side of myself since I
was very very small you know I'm being a
little silly here but this is a way for
us to see that when we pay attention to
the inner world and begin to lessen our
excessive attention to the outer world a
balancing or compensatory action in the
psyche is stimulated so the persona is a
mediator between the external world of
others and the ego recall that I
suggested earlier that you should think
of the persona as a defense for the ego
but in our last podcast episode on the
anima and the animus I said that these
archetypes are mediators between the
internal world and the ego so we can
imagine the persona and the anima or
animus to be opposites they fulfill very
opposite roles for the persona dealing
with the external world and the ego and
for the anima or animus dealing with the
ego and the internal world both are
critical in the process of adaptation
something I want to deal with in a
future episode